Ich bin Herr Karach. Ich bin auch dieses Astraz-Astraz-Statik und würde gerne mit Ihnen das auch noch mit dem Gespräch führen.
Bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid, oder fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Guten Abend Herr Dr. Karach. Gerne.
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Mein Name ist Manfred Poker.
Könnten Sie Ihren Nachnamen Buch stabilen?
Ja natürlich. Paul Otto Caesar, Karl Emil Richard.
Danke schön.
Herr Poker, jetzt werde ich einige Fragen stellen.
Sind Sie einverstanden?
Deswegen bin ich da Herr Doktor.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 23. Mai 1968.
Ja, und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter 78.
Wie wiegen Sie?
Und ich wiege circa 95 kg.
Herr Poker, was für Bescheid haben Sie im Moment?
Herr Doktor, ich hatte vor ca. 4 Wochen meine Boosterinfunkte mit Moderna.
Danach war es eigentlich sehr gut.
Ich hatte überhaupt keine Probleme.
Ich hatte nur leicht in den ersten 2 Tagen etwas Fieber.
Aber danach war alles sehr gut.
Jetzt habe ich seit 3-4 Tagen ein Husten und ich bekomme schlecht Luft.
Wie oft hast du das gesehen?
Alle paar Minuten, sobald ich anfange zu laufen.
Ich bekomme schlecht Luft, ich merke, dass die Luft etwas schlecht ist.
Ich muss ständig husten.
Ständig husten?
Ja.
Haben Sie Luft noch?
Ja, wenn ich mich anspreng, ich merke, dass ich schlechter Luft bekomme.
Das reicht schon, wenn ich in der Wohnung von einem Zimmer in das andere Zimmer laufe.
Ich merke, dass die Luft sofort schlecht wird.
Sind die Husten trockener oder mit Ausruf?
Es ist eher trocken.
Ich habe immer so ein Kratzen im Hals.
Aber wenn ich Luft einmal ein- und ausatme, dann habe ich das Gefühl, es feicht manchmal ein bisschen auf den Bronch.
Haben Sie Schmerzen beim Husten?
Wenn ich lange huste, dann tut mir der Brustkorb.
Entschuldige mich, wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen Wasser trinke.
Gibt es bestimmte Ausflöße, selbst für die Husten?
Für den Husten?
Ich habe es seit drei Tagen, und das ist alle paar Minuten.
Manchmal geht es sehr lang, manchmal geht es auch nur ganz kurz.
Aber in den bestimmten Ausflößen gibt es nicht.
Was ist mir noch?
Gibt es Faktoren, die beschwerden Lindern oder Prästarken?
Was ich jetzt heute Abend merke, ist, dass ich auf einen sehr schnellen Puls habe.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass mein Herz sehr schnell schlägt.
Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden?
Hatten Sie ähnliche Beschwerden früher schon einmal?
Nein, so etwas hatte ich bisher noch nicht.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber habe ich jetzt nicht bekommen.
Schütte Brust?
Nein, das auch nicht, aber ich fühle mich schon sehr geschwächt.
Mütter, oder?
Ja, sehr müder.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit die Wichtsfeldveränderungen gemerkt?
Nein, ich bin immer eigentlich vom Gewicht her gleichgeblieben.
Da habe ich hier bisher keine Probleme mehr.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserläsern oder durchschwägen?
Nein, bisher war alles in Ordnung.
Da habe ich keine Schwierigkeiten.
Haben Sie Überkeit, Wäsche, Duschmein?
Nein, das alles nicht.
Aber wenn ich sehr lange husten muss, dann bekomme ich manchmal auch so ein Brechreiz.
Aber so ein Erbrechen oder einen Durchfall hatte ich bisher nicht.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Haben Sie Probleme bei einer Duschleistung?
Ja, also seit gestern, wenn ich mich hinlege, dann bekomme ich auch schlechter Luft.
Im Sitz sind alles okay, aber sobald ich mich hinlege, habe ich das Gefühl,
dass die Luft schlecht wird.
Können Sie flach liegen, ohne Luft noch zu bekommen?
Sehr schlecht.
Also flach liegen, klappt eigentlich nicht mehr.
Ich musste meinen Kopfteil ein bisschen erhöhen.
Und wie gesagt, seit heute habe ich so ein Herzhasen,
und dann ist es mit der Luft noch mal schlechter geworden.
Wie ist dir Appetit?
Haben Sie Appetit discount?
Das ist eigentlich okay, Appetit ist gut.
Haben Sie feuchte, wärme Hände oder...
Die Hände?
An den Händen habe ich bisher nichts gemerkt.
Oder Sitzern gemerkt, haben Sie denn?
Ein Zitter? Nein.
Okay.
Herr Böker, ich werde einige Fragen zu Ihrer Vollgeschichte stellen.
Haben Sie einen krönchen Erkrankungen?
Als Erkrankungen habe ich bisher nicht.
Mein Haushaltsmeinte, ich war vor kurzem zu einem Checkup,
dass mein Blutdruck leicht erhöht ist,
und er hat mich gewarnt und gesagt, ich soll mit dem Rauchen aufhören.
Rauchen aufhören? Ja.
Aber Blutdruck ist nicht diagnostisiert?
Ist nur leicht erhöht, ich soll es kontrollieren.
Medikamente habe ich nicht bekommen.
Noch andere Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Nehmen Sie Regen- oder Gelegen- technikal- Mantel?
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ich habe mal einen Leistenbruch gehabt, auf der rechten Seite.
Das liegt aber schon lange zurück, so circa 20 Jahre.
Noch andere?
Nein.
Haben Sie eine Erkrankung?
Ich bin gegen Penicillin und Voltarene aller Erkrankungen.
Und zuletzt habe ich auch ein neues Medikament bekommen.
Aber ich habe den Namen vergessen, das hat es mir auch nicht gut getan.
Wie groß hat es sich überleitet?
Ich bekomme einen Yukreiz am ganzen Körper.
Es treten rote Punkte am Körper auf.
So ähnlich ist es mit fast allen Medikamenten, auf die ich allergisch bin.
Haben Sie Unterdrücklichkeiten?
Ja, ich vertrage Milch nicht so gut.
Ich kann auch keine Äpfel essen.
Eier sind auch manchmal ein kleines Problem.
Wie ist Ihr Impfstatus?
Mein Haushalt hat alles aktualisiert.
Ich war vor ein, zwei Monaten dort.
Er hat alle irgendwo aufgefrischt.
Ich habe einen sehr stressigen Job.
Ich rauche ungefähr eine Packung pro Tag.
Das geht schon seit fast 30 Jahren.
Ich rauche auch schon sehr lange.
Ich habe eine sehr stresige Arbeit.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nicht immer ab und zu.
Haben Sie jemals Drogenkonsum jetzt, wenn ich dragen darf?
Drum?
Nein.
Ich habe manchmal etwas hasch gehabt.
Aber ansonsten habe ich keine Drogen.
Hast du noch?
Und gibt es Leben Ihrer Eltern noch?
Meine Eltern leben noch.
Und denen geht es eigentlich ganz gut.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ich habe noch eine ältere Schwester.
Meine Schwester leidet an Diabetes.
Ich habe noch mal etwas gesagt.
Aber das ist etwas Gynokologisches.
Aber ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Aber ist anscheinend nichts Schlimmes.
Was ist Ihr Beruf, Herr Werken?
Ich bin selbstständig.
Ich habe ein Textilgeschäft.
Und ich verkaufe Kleider.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe einen Sohn und eine Tochter.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ich bin gesund.
Den Kindern geht es gut.
Wohnen Sie allein oder mit Ihrer Frau?
Nein, ich wohne mit meiner Familie.
Frau und Kinder.
Herr Pfaker,
jetzt habe ich das
ein Textilgeschäft so weit abgeschlossen.
Was ist es, Herr Pfaker?
Ich habe noch etwas zu tun.
Was ist es, Herr Doktor?
Ich mache mir Sorgen.
Ich bin jetzt zu Ihnen gekommen.
Herr Pfaker, es ist so flüch,
eine Diagnose zu stellen.
Ich möchte Ihnen kurz erklären,
was wir weiter vorgehen wollen.
Ich werde Sie weiter informieren.
Vielen Dank.
Ich hoffe, dass ich da etwas finde.
Ich bin Ihnen sehr dankbar, Herr Doktor.
Sie waren sehr freundlich.
Danke.
Darf ich etwas fragen?
Ja, bitte.
Ich habe eine Diagnose.
Ich habe die Diagnose.
Mit meinen Beinen.
three days i have additional diagnose.
Beine und warm.
Nein, es ist keine Rötung.
Wir haben keine Rötung.
meinen Kopf sein kann ich elektrisch verschieben. Ich habe es ungefähr so bei 30 Grad ungefähr gehabt.
Danke. Wo ist mein Doktor hin? Doktor wollen wir jetzt die Übergabe machen. Jetzt Doktor Karaj,
Übergabe an den Oberarzt und dann können wir die weiteren Möglichkeiten dann besprechen.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt. Guten Tag Herr Doktor Karaj, bitte schön, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich möchte Ihnen über eine Patience berichten, haben Sie kurz Zeit.
Für Sie doch immer Herr Karaj, natürlich bitte schön. Dann legen Sie mal los.
Der Patient heißt Malfit Package und 54 Jahre alt, 178 cm groß, 95 kg schwer.
Herr Städte sich bei uns wegen persisterender, trockener Husten seit drei Tagen vor.
Er hat vor drei Wochen eine Impfung gegen Corona bekommen, eine moderne Impfung.
Er berichtete das LHW Dispner und Orthopner.
Er hatte auch eine instabilte AP, Sie haben nicht gefragt, den Patient.
Ich habe ihn bei den Beinen aufgefallen.
Die Frage nach Fieber, Schüttebrot, Nachschweißburg, Berlin.
Die vegetative Anängese sei unabhängig bis auf Schlachtstörung wegen Orthopner.
An Vorerkrankungen sei leichter durch die Hochdruckbekannt.
An Vorerkrankungen sei in Grüne Herne die Operation vor 20 Jahren bekannt.
Er hatte Anängese gegen Finnisch und Wotere mit Bürovitis und Exantem.
Er hatte Intolenz gegen Finnisch und Wotere.
Seine Impfstatus sei vollständig.
Er raffert 20 Becken.
Er trinkt Alkohol, drohige Konsum wurde verneinst.
Er hat seine Schwester, seine Schwester, leider nicht mit der Diabetes Mentor.
Er hat eine unbekannte, unkollegische Erkrankung.
Ich darf eine Minute kurz aufhauen.
Er hat zwei Kinder und wohnt mit seiner Frau.
Mit seiner Frau?
Mit seiner Frau.
Ich habe die Akzent an der Musee geholfen.
Ich helfe sie inzwischen aus.
Aber eins haben Sie vergessen.
Ein Soetom, Tarekadi.
Er hatte Herzrasen.
Haben Sie nicht gesagt.
Haben Sie vergessen bei der Vorstellung.
Der Patient hat berichtet,
dass er seit einem Tag ein schnelles Herz hat.
Ein schnelles Herzfrequenz.
Da haben Sie nicht gefragt,
ist es regelmäßig, ist es unregelmäßig?
Das haben Sie jetzt auch vergessen.
Das heißt, vielleicht ein Tipp noch,
bevor Sie Ihre Differenzialdiagnosen aufzählen,
beim Abröhrchen, also bei der Auskundung der Lunge,
hört man feuchte Rasselgeräusche
und er hat einen Herzfrequenz bei ca. 150.
Es ist arrhythmisch das EKG.
Jetzt bitte Ihre Differenzialdiagnosen.
Das Erste war schon mal ganz gut.
Sie denken ein Herzinsuffizien.
Worauf, Bürohänd, woher kommend?
Er ist ja noch sehr jung, 54 Jahre alt,
keine Vorerkrankung.
Das kann die Ursache für diese Herz.
Wie lange ist die Carditis?
Wegen der Impfung, meinen Sie?
Nein.
Eine Herzinsuffizienz,
aufgrund der Carditis, nach Corona-Impfung.
Zweitens wegen der Herzfrequenz,
unregelmäßig, arrhythmisch und schnell.
Woran denken Sie, welche Diagnose?
Das ist eine Tachiaritmy.
Das kann auch eine Herzinsuffizienz machen.
Sehr gut.
Was noch?
Die Fernseher.
Was haben die Kollegen?
Eine Pneumonie,
eine Diagnose,
eine Pneumonie,
auch wenn er kein Fieber hat,
eine Pneumonie.
Eine Lungenembole,
eine Arithmie,
eine Tiefe bei,
eine Lungenembole auslösen.
Woran denken Sie noch?
Verrückt.
Was ist das?
Eine potheokalizierte CoPD.
Die ist nicht erkannt.
Das sehen Sie mit einer Röntgen,
das ist natürlich sehr gut.
Die ist gestaut,
eine zentrale Stauung.
Es ist eine zentrale Staunung mit einem Ultraschall können Sie sehen, ob er ein pleurer Erguss hat.
Und ob er ein großes Herz oder ein kleines Herz hat, sehr gut.
Mit dem EKG können Sie sehen, wie schnell er ist und ob der Rhythmus arhythmisch ist oder rhythmisch ist.
Also ein Sinus-Rhythmus oder eine Daffer-Rhythmie.
Woran muss man natürlich immer denken?
Das Herz.
Das kann auch mal der Beginn eines Herzinfarktes sein, der Grund für die Herzinsuffizienz.
Kann auch deswegen auch die Frage mit der instabilen AP, also instabile Angina-Pectoris erhaucht.
Er hat ein entsprechendes Alter und hat eine Risikofaktoren.
Das heißt, es kann auch mal ein Herzinfarkt natürlich sein.
Daran muss man auch denken.
Das heißt, 3 Tage lang kann sein, dass es immer wieder so kleinere Herzinfarkte sind.
Dass ein peripheres Gefäß zugeht, aufgeht, aufgeht, aufgeht.
Das kann schon mal passieren.
Okay, sehr gut.
Vielen Dank, das war sehr gut, Herr Dr. Karach.
Haben die anderen Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch eine Frage?
Das ist ein sehr guter Ansatz.
Aber das ist nicht falsch.
Wir haben zum Beispiel für Morbus Crohn,
dass wir ihn für die Ängste der Darbation vertreten.
Morbus Crohn, das kann man auch sagen.
Das ist ein sehr guter Ansatz.
Das heißt, es ist ein sehr guter Ansatz.
Morbus Crohn, da.
Oder dann können wir ihn doch.
Warum bringen wir ihn jetzt in Türkisch? Bitte auf Deutsch.
Sehr gut.
Okay, das war ein Patient, das, was ich Ihnen jetzt vorgestellt habe.
Ein Patient von mir, der diese Woche ins Krankenhaus gekommen ist.
Bei dem wurde jetzt die erste Diagnose eine Tafiare-Tmiya absolute,
also Vorhof-Limmen, festgestellt.
Er ist jetzt eine lunge Idee.
Er ist jetzt seit drei Tagen in den Krankenhaus.
Er hat eine diuretische Medikation bekommen.
Er hat Antiarhythmika-Therapie bekommen.
Heute sollte er ein Herzkatheter bekommen.
Der Rhythmus ist stabilisiert worden nach einer Elektro-Kardio-Version.
Er ist von einer Tachyarhythmi in einen Sinus-Rhythmus konvertiert.
Er ist, der Rhythmus ist jetzt stabil geworden.
Ist eine Teilwendung zusammen Impfung?
Ich denke er nicht.
Es sind vier Wochen vorbei seit der Impfung.
Meistens hat man in den ersten ein paar Tagen oder eine Woche diese Symptome.
Das ist eher unwahrscheinlich, dass diese Symptome von der Info kommen.
Myokaditis vielleicht ja, das beginnt so nach zwei, drei Wochen, glaube ich.
Das kann schon mal sein, ist aber sehr, sehr.
Was braucht er jetzt für eine Medikation, Herr Doktor?
Letzte Frage.
Wenn er jetzt eine Erstdiagnose von Vorhof-Limmen hat,
welche Medikamente braucht der Patient?
Was für ein Facharzt sind Sie, Herr Doktor?
Oh, genau.
Entschuldigung.
Dann nehme ich die Frage zurück.
Aber einst müssen Sie wissen, er braucht etwas wie den Rhythmus.
Vielleicht hinterm Rhythmus.
Und vielleicht erbraucht er eine Antikoagulation.
Markumar ist in der Zwischenzeit etwas altmodisch.
Man nimmt die neueren Antikoagulanzien, Heliquis, Xarelto usw.
Eine Antikoagulation und ein Rhythmus, eine Frequenz stabilisierendes Medikament,
zum Beispiel ein Peterbocken.
Erstlinie Antikoagulation.
Ja, und ein drittes Medikament, da er in der Herzinsuffizienz ist,
braucht er auch eine Therapie gegen die Herzinsuffizienz.
Und dann nimmt man zwei wichtige Medikamente.
Eins, welches ist das Eins?
Wer hilft, welche Internisten sind da?
Wo sind die Internisten?
Ein ACE-Hemmer, zum Beispiel Rami Pri, der wollte.
Und zweitens, weil er einen Lungen in dem hatte, das brauchte noch.
Die Eurethika?
Ein Diurethikum, sehr gut. Zum Beispiel Thorazemith.
Sehr gut. Also wunderbare Therapie.
Passt es, Christian Merlin, vielen Dank.
Oder sind noch Fragen?
Keine Fragen.
Das war sehr gut, Herr Dr. Karra. Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg bei der Prüfung.
Und allen anderen natürlich auch.
Und einen schönen Abend.